to clarify the government's not having
their lives it's authorizing them to
think of their own the government is
authorizing medical professionals to
authorize and administer and by the way
you want to get one next level uh down
into this conspiracy theory Rabbit Hole
of of of
insanity Nova Scotia New Brunswick
recently enacted uh they called it the
Allen Law in Nova Scotia or New
Brunswick I forget which one presumed
consent for tissue harvesting
presumed consent so they're going to
change the law to be that you have to
opt out of organ doning organ donation
tissue donation and you're presumed to
have opted in unless you opt out every
citizen every every there's some
criteria as to how long you've had to
live in The Province but it's the trend
now presumption of organ donation tissue
donation and by the way you don't even
have to be dead for it to happen yet you
can have a medical profession I forget
what they're called not the corner but
basically something to determined you're
close enough to dying uh so therefore
you're presumed to have don't uh you
know surrendered your tissue